St only one suspect in the brutal
beating of the four nypt office NYPD
officers last week is currently held on
a $1 155,000 bail investigators say
they're still trying to track down all
those who took part in the attack some
of the men were arrested and released
with no bail but officials say the worst
offenders are still on the Run we want
to bring in New York congresswoman
Nicole motakis it's great to have you
here and New York City council member
Vicki Paladino because this story is
getting a lot of national attention do
you do we know where these migrants are
well basically rumor has it because they
they're free they're out uh no charges
no nothing they're out try to find them
Rumor Has It California that's what they
say how did they get from New York to
California they are free to roam as they
please this is all how bad is the city
council or not how mad is the city
council I don't think the city council
has moved at all because had it not been
covered in the news and I'm sitting here
before you today they could care less so
uh what we're learning New York Post is
report we thought on Friday that a
faith-based group of which so people who
don't live in New York just so you know
the faith gra uh faith-based groups are
they run the interface for all the
migrants throughout the city uh and they
help them in all the different bureaus
we thought on Friday they were helped by
a faith-based group to get on a bus
apparently that's not the case the post
is reporting that police have an idea of
where the men are I think here's the
fundamental question if you're a
Democratic leader in the city of New
York today what do you want to do do you
want to allow these men to go ahead and
dissolve back into the Border across in
New Mexico and the story is forgotten or
do you arrest them apprehend them bring
them back to New York City before a
judge and get weeks of terrible
publicity for awful policies well I know
that New Yorkers want to see these
individuals held accountable and I think
it goes back to the laws that uh Bill
DeBlasio passed 2014 that prohibits NYPD
from cooperating with Immigration and
Customs Enforcement to have these
individuals deported literally a
detainer request can be on any
individual including the one who
committed Murder By the way at the
Roosevelt migrant uh Center and uh they
will release that individual back onto
the street if they're not going to jail
uh and and and instead of deporting that
individual working with ice they've
they've actually denied every single
detainer request and we know that
thousands of in there at least been a
thousand individuals
at these migrant encampments that have
committed crimes in the city everything
from assult to robbery to Grand larsy to
stabbing and a murder uh and and these
cops weren't the first to be assaulted
people should know that there was a
woman who slapped a police officer
outside his shelter um there was also a
DUI arrest by of a migrant that ended up
biting the finger of a NYPD sergeant and
these people are back on the street I
mean somebody who pickpocketed eight
times arrested released back onto the
street to go one of to one of these l
we saw the governor of New York on that
subway car last week say if you mess
with our cops you will not you will pay
the price will will she follow up on her
own words the one thing the governor of
the state of New York has the ability to
do is to actually fire people like brag
and she could she could do away with the
law that was passed in 2017
2014 this is all within her grasp
they're not doing anything ask yourself
why why aren't they doing anything I've
held the governor of this state
accountable for every single thing
that's happened with the Migra with the
immigration and the illegal aliens
flooding invading our city since this
started okay and yet they all talk the
talk nobody wants to actually do what
needs to be done and you brought up a
good point as a Democrat leader in a
city and state such as New York don't
you want to actually do something so
that there's finally a decent headline
about you no they don't care this is a
whole new New Yorkers now back in March
of 22 that's how they were titling them
the new New Yorkers so as 400,000 New
Yorkers left the city of New York we got
new ones we got new ones the other thing
is uh congresswoman that mayor Adams has
this new pilot program right 553 million
that would go on cards basically this is
the
mayor these would be debit cards this
says not only will this money provide
families with the ability to purchase
fresh food for their culturally relevant
diets and the baby supplies of their
choosing but the pilot program is
expected to save New York City more than
$600,000 per month or more than $7.2
million annually I mean does he have a
point is this a better way to try to
deal with the situation we could
actually save taxpayers billions of
dollars if he just stops offering any of
these free incentives that's what's
attracting people to come to New York
City so the president may have created
this crisis with his executive orders
but our mayor and our governor keep uh
helping it perpetuate perpetuate it by
offering all these things and again
somebody gets arrested they get released
back into the street they go back to
their luxury hotel room paid by the
taxpayers and then they're going to
receive a debit card on top of it a 500
migrant families initially if if it's
successful they're going to get
150,000 migrants here quick thought on
once again $7.3 billion do we are over
budget right now 7 .3 billion how much
more are we going to do of this honestly
and with the city council that we have
right now overriding anything that the
mayor is trying to do uh to help protect
our law enforcement is falling flat we
call upon the governor of the state of
New York I call upon my city council
it's time for real action and real
Common Sense here and we're not getting
it great to have you both here the New
York strong women I love it good to have
you thank you hey everyone I'm Emily
compano catch me and my co-hosts Harris
vulner and Kaye mechineni on outnumbered
every weekday at 12:00 p.m. Eastern or
set your DVR also don't forget to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
for daily highlights